[Music]
hi
there i'm regan
oh oh my god are you are you okay yeah
yeah i'm fine
i'm regan this is um unfortunately a
very accurate
first impression
nice to meet you hey josh okay yeah
nathan's just not reachable i don't know
when he's coming back
actually don't even know where he went
maybe there oh wow
good digging you are a reporter really
impressive
do you do cardio or is it mostly pilates
um what were you hoping to ask him
uh well i saw a video online of nathan
from
founder's day he
seems really passionate about his family
lineage and
this statue
big larry yes
i think i know what you're talking about
well it seemed like the story might
resonate with the rest of the country
the united states yeah that one national
news
very exciting um well i
am in charge of the museum today and i
would love to show you around
why don't we check out the east gallery
what do you think you're doing nathan
couldn't handle some dumb podcast
how's it gonna do with a smart crafty
annoyingly hot reporter by the way could
have used a little heads up on that
i told you he was hot not centaur hot
whatever we just need to keep it cool
and
show him that there is no story in this
boring boring town
[Music]
[Applause]